as somebody who's
youngish and stepping into that how
would you go about what advice would you
give young women who are maybe trying to
find say a high value man what can they
do what steps can they take because
obviously from my perspective and the
past relationships I've been in it's
been it's hard
to give that treatment to a guy who for
example my ex he would I'd pay for
everything I was working I was paying
for the rent and he still had a lot of
um he had lotes of insecurities and he
you know push me to do a lot of things
um and then you just think well why
would I do that for you when you're not
doing your part as a man in my opinion
so how would I your question was you
know High it you know included the
phrase high value man right and a high
value man is not unemployed unable to
like like a guy that's considered top
shelf you know in my opinion is
competent is resourceful is a good man
is good at being a man has combat skills
knows how to make it rain knows how to
make money can solve problems like you
know high value men are not just
masculine looking strong and attractive
like you know I think most women would
uh conventionally say Brad Pit George
Clooney blah blah blah you know stuff
like that that's not that's not just it
because women have a long laundry list
of boxes that need to get ticked off so
why would you even waste your time with
a guy that you've identified that is a
high value guy that's just another notch
to put on your bed post that is there in
your
history yeah true because he was cute my
friends were there I was drunk he was
drunk it was fun so we just did it like
that's usually the reasoning that most
women sort of default to is they don't
think about future ideas and concept
sort of thing it's like you know if you
want to again you know because a high
value man especially a guy that's
traveling in my circles like you know
friends of mine sort of stuff they're
going to look at a gal's past right and
it's like well you've got a nothing but
a series of bad choices behind you you
know like if you've got nothing but a
bad sequence of bad choice after bad
choice after bad choice it's like how am
I supposed to lead this
chick yeah
you so I think that being being very
intentional and fastidious with your
time and your dating is really really
important I mean that's advice I would
give to my daughter yeah don't waste
your time dating losers
I don't care how [__] cuute he is I
don't care if he has a motorcycle if he
just got out of jail and a 72 tattoos
and jacked the [__] I don't get
why right WEP women on oh go ahead
Rich go ahead mff sorry oh I was just
gonna say we had a couple women on a
couple weeks ago who were know 21 I
think 22 and they were you know they had
they have like most women have they have
these sort of goals of I want a high
value guy I want a guy that makes a lot
of money I want him to be rich I want
him to be competent I want him to be
able to you know get stuff done but I
also want to go study abroad and live in
Amsterdam for six months or I just wanna
like do this or whatever I want to just
you know go beond the yachts in Miami
because the the idea that a lot of these
women have is that their Runway never
ends and the attention that they're
going to be getting at 21 is the same
attention they're going to be getting at
31 at 41 at 51
because they they they they have a hard
time planning and thinking for the
future right because since the beginning
in Dawn Of Time women have never been on
their own they've always been taken care
of or somebody's always been there to
provide and protect for them and lead
them you know there's not a single
matriarchal society that has ever
survived into the modern world
so this idea like that the idea that
they may have to suffer consequences and
repercussions for their choices is very
foreign to most women and so they can
just make whatever decision that they
that they want to and they don't have to
think about consequences and they can
just I'll just figure it out it's very
fly by the seat of their pants kind of
of going about
life and your time is finite and
especially as a woman like your window
of the kind of guy that you really want
and you got sort of a you know if you're
lucky you can extend I would say
probably 10 years or so if you're lucky
you can extend that maybe 15 or 20 into
your mid-30s or 40s but for most women
out there
you've got from about 20 to about 27 28
29 to if if your goal is to get the guy
and to be married and have kids and have
a family that's your window for the most
part now I think we catch a lot of flak
sometimes
because we don't we don't sit here and
say women shouldn't work women shouldn't
go have careers women shouldn't go make
a bunch of money if that's what they
want to do but what we say is that women
can't have it all and you have got to
essentially choose and you've got to
choose early because all of those things
take time right so if you want to
dedicate the next 20 years of your life
to going and building a career and
making a bunch of money cool you're
probably not going to get the guy that
you want now if you want to get a guy
that you want then you're you're
probably going to have to be okay with
not making as much money not necessarily
being able to financially support
yourself and buying every single little
thing that you want to buy like handbags
and shoes and all that other
[__] but nobody's having these
conversations with women telling them
that it's a give and take with
everything because they've always since
they've been little have been given and
given and given and they've never had to
trade anything off there's no cost
benefit analysis that they do so it's
all about figuring out what you want
figuring out the steps to get there and
then going forth and and putting those
steps into practice and it sounds simple
but a lot of women just can't wrap their
minds around that a lot of a lot of
getting what you want out of life I
think think is is sometimes it it's
easier just being clear on what you
don't want yeah right and if you just
stop doing things that you don't want
then you lean more into what you're
looking for you know what I mean like
you know for younger gals in their 20s
um you know they want to find a high
value man so let's use that
example uh put yourself in places that
high value men go
to
give give High value men something to
look at you know because they're
obviously going to look at your beauty
because women are Beauty objects I mean
the notion of high value man explicitly
states he has high value which is
inherently tied into his ability to make
it rain and to make money and solve
problems and be competent and
influential and all that sort of stuff
right
compelling so you know putting yourself
in those places and then when you find
these guys just be just again you know
guys want
a woman that won't be with just anybody
right if he knows that you've been
around from guy to guy to guy to guy or
you've dated some of his friends or you
know extended people from his friends or
certain people in work
like the reason why [__] shaming used to
be a thing and really isn't a thing
anymore is because it is because it
worked shaming Works in general you know
you know you broke shame somebody
they're going to like you know you make
fun of somebody oh nice car it's a piece
of [__] it's you know it's a Honda or
something like that and it's a guy with
a German car making fun you then you
know you want to work your way up into a
German car and then you get a German car
and a guy with an Italian car goes oh
nice German car speak Andy do hahaa a j
he'll make fun of you because he's got
an Italian car now right sort of thing
right you want to work your way up into
an Italian car or a British you know
sports car so you know shaming does work
um but we don't do it anymore so I don't
think I mean we still do it it's just
not done as much or it's not as overt or
as public but I think that you know if
you're super intentional and understand
that you've only got so much runway in
your life and there is a hard stop there
is an end and that for women that their
beauty and their looks do have an expiry
date like I think joyon would you know
agree that she's at at 46 not as
competitive as a 26y old oh absolutely a
lot of women don't like that yeah yeah
they oh they hate it we've had we've had
women lie to us in their for oh I don't
dye my hair my hair is naturally always
all black
[__] right so it's it's you know
it's just a it's just a reality of of
you know like human nature and I think
that um I think it's a great question to
ask and it's just putting yourself in an
environment where high value men are not
dealing with low value men and and
making yourself the kind of thing that
high value men want to be attracted like
chicks love the whole manifesting and
the sun and the moon and the stars and
the crystals like I get it I get it you
know if you want to manifest the guy
hope is a shitty plan but do the things
that that that that these guys that you
want uh you know you want bees become
honey right so you know you just do and
become the thing that things that these
guys want and you know keep putting
yourself in an environment in a place
and stay away from the [__] otherwise
you will attract flies you know flies go
to [__] I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if if you're new
to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out